[Musica]
nel 2017 samantha rivelasse elettronica
festival in arrivo che era intatta che
era perfetta era stata appena stata
costruita dalle mani molto abili di
programmatori ingegneri però il suo
esser intatta non durò molto a lungo
perché dopo un poco tempo che samantha
era lì alla fiera fu toccata da mani
maschili e quindi si trova la rotta in
vari punti e molto presto samantha non è
una donna era una bambola anzi per dirla
più chiaramente samantha era un android
è una di quelle che andrei di quelle
bambole robotiche che vengono costruite
e messe sul mercato per il puro piacere
maschile
alexa accendi la televisione e alexa
ordiniamo una pizza quante volte si
sentono queste cose nelle nostre case
con i bambini che crescono pensando che
sia normale ordinare ad un assistente
virtuale dal nome femminile e dalla voce
femminile ordinare cosa fare per loro in
questa nuova forma di servitù digitale
questi assistenti virtuali sono lì a
obbedire a non contraddire a fare quello
che gli altri vogliono ma non è solo
harmony non è solo alexa non è solo
cortana o siri pensiamo per esempio a
compass l'algoritmo utilizzato il
software utilizzato dal sistema
penitenziario americano questo banco
questo software veniva utilizzato per
definire il tasso di recidivi smo dei
prigionieri
questo software era considerato razzista
perché nonostante il crimine commesso
automaticamente dava un tasso di
recidivi smo più alto a nieri che ai
bianchi e pensiamo ad esempio a il
l'algoritmo utilizzato in gran bretagna
l'anno scorso soste per sostituire gli
esami non si potevano fare gli esami a
causa del coro da virus e allora il
governo britannico
utilizziamo un algoritmo per dare un
voto questi studenti
ecco anche questa anche questo algoritmo
non andò molto bene
fu ritirato perché questo algoritmo
privilegiava gli studenti delle scuole
private a scapito degli studenti delle
scuole pubbliche e per la prima volta a
londra c'è stata una manifestazione
contro un algoritmo e per non parlare
della carta di credito di apple goldman
sachs che dava un credito più limitato a
una donna che a suo marito nonostante
vaccino finanziario fosse lo stesso
cosa hanno in comune tutte queste storie
che ha voluto raccontare quello che
hanno in comune queste storie è
semplicemente il fatto che la ci
mostrano che la tecnologia non è neutra
la tecnologia non è neutra perché un
prodotto tecnologico un artefatto
tecnologico è in realtà un artefatto
socio politico ed è socio politico
perché è costruito da qualcuno
opera in un ambiente e si nutre di dati
che nei membri non sono e come fanno a
essere neutri da i dati sono lo specchio
della società per come oggi è come fare
una fotografia e come fare una
fotografia della società e dire ecco i
dati allora questi dati rappresentano le
disuguaglianze sociali rappresentano le
disuguaglianze economiche della nostra
società per come oggi sono qui davanti a
noi
e quindi cosa succede quando questi dati
che rappresentano decenni secoli di
disuguaglianze sociali vengono poi dati
in pasto ad algoritmi che hanno sempre
di più una funzione allocativa sulla
nostra società sempre di più una
funzione amministrativa decidono se
possiamo essere assunti
se possiamo essere promossi se possiamo
avere un prestito oppure no
decidono se possiamo avere accesso ad
una casa un servizio bene quando questi
dati vengono dati in pasto ad algoritmi
che hanno funzione così potente nella
nostra società
allora il rischio vero è che tramite
questi dati non neutri si automatizzano
le disuguaglianze sociali se
automatizzano con le forme di
oppressione che ci sono nella società di
oggi
se software igino quelle dinamite e che
si amplificano diventino poi talmente
tanto pack difficile da contestare
e questo è un rischio che non possiamo
correre un rischio pericoloso che non
possiamo correre perché con gli
algoritmi che diventano sempre più
importanti nella nostra società noi non
possiamo permetterci che la tecnologia
ci porta indietro
automatizzando le disuguaglianze sociali
che ci sono nel nostro mondo
e allora che cosa possiamo fare in
queste circostanze ci sono tre cose
secondo me che possiamo fare la prima e
non avere paura non avere paura della
terminologia non avere paura della
parola l'intelligenza artificiale che in
realtà non è né intelligente né
artificiale e sicuramente non è
artificiale perché si nutre di dati dei
dati di cui abbiamo parlato
non avere paura e anzi avere il coraggio
di fare come facciamo quando andiamo del
supermercato e guardiamo un prodotto che
vogliamo comprare e mangiare e guardiamo
gli ingredienti vediamo di cosa è fatto
e noi dobbiamo fare lo stesso con questi
artefatti tecnologici guardare di che
nato dati si sono nutriti guardare dove
sono stati creati guardare quanto sono
trasparenti ed è il coraggio veramente
di capirli e di chiedere informazioni su
questi sistemi sulle decisioni che
prendono e mai assumere che queste
decisioni siano neutre perché neutre non
possono essere la seconda cosa che
dobbiamo fare è programmarli questi
sistemi
ci sono troppe poche donne troppo poco
dai dallas
c'e troppo epoche e provenienze d'acqua
nelle stanze dove si decide a quali dati
vanno in questo sistema in questi
sistemi è ok nelle stanze dove si decide
che prodotti creare e per quale scopo
allora il link diventa importante che ci
sia quella diversity là dove si
costruiscono questi sistemi
perché così io sono sicura che con più
diversity quale domande che sono
essenziali le domande di inclusività di
rappresentatività dei dati quale domande
verranno poste qualcuno chiederà qual è
l'effetto di questi sistemi suoi più
vulnerabili nella nostra società
se a decidere la tecnologia codificarla
ea programmarla sono solo maschi bianchi
allora la prospettiva sarà una sola e
quella prospettiva una sola non
permetterà di valutare le ampie
conseguenze di un sistema di
intelligenza artificiale e la terza cosa
sono le regole non bisogna avere paura
delle regole ci viene spesso detto che
siccome siamo in una corsa globale verso
l'innovazione la l'intelligenza
artificiale e siamo a competere su scala
globale allora non c'è spazio per le
regole e le regole ci dicono
oppure è la l'innovazione
ecco io non ci credo io non ci credo che
sia così le regole o innovazione e non
ci credo perché non si fa innovazione
sulle spalle di un progresso non si fa
innovazione sulle spalle delle donne non
si fa innovazione involando i sacrifici
e la lotta che è stata fatta prima
disuguaglianza per la parità una lotta
che sicuramente non compiuta e
sicuramente ancora da finire ancora
tanta strada c'è da fare ma sicuramente
non possiamo fermarla sull'altare della
cosiddetta innovazione tecnologica e
innovazione e regole possono andare
insieme anzi devono andare insieme
perché più c'è progresso
nell'innovazione più c'è innovazione
perché la gente si fiderà di questi
prodotti
perché questi prodotti saranno a
servizio di tutti non di pochi
e allora io penso che sia arrivato il
momento di difenderla questa tecnologia
di difenderla nel senso che dobbiamo
proteggere il nostro ambiente digitale
in cui viviamo l'ambiente non è solo
quello fisico che ci circonda la mente
ora è anche quello digitale e quindi
dobbiamo dobbiamo difenderlo e dobbiamo
fare in modo davvero che questa
innovazione che è così importante perché
è bella la tecnologia bella
l'intelligenza artificiale delle
promesse enormi per tutti quanti però
dobbiamo veramente fare in modo che
questa innovazione non avvenga
sacrificando le battaglie di anni fatte
spesi da tanti battaglia ancora
incompiute nel cammino verso
l'uguaglianza e soprattutto non dobbiamo
fare in modo che questi algoritmi non
facciano altro che a riportarci dalla
finestra ciò che abbiamo voluto e
continuiamo a combattere per tanto tempo
l'innovazione è bella la tecnologia è
bella ma è bella se ne beneficiano tutti
e non solamente ai ruoli